♪ Started my life was kind of rough ♪
♪ I had an uphill battle ♪
♪ The doctor sat my parents down ♪
♪ And said my life was fragile ♪
♪ Practice with the game ♪
♪ And guarantee the name ♪
♪ It's what you had to do to work ♪
♪ And everything would change ♪
♪ Sympathy help the (indistinct) ♪
♪ Yet that's what I wanted ♪
♪ Being patient hell the
tricky after being honest ♪
♪ Tea With Garyvee, full
of positivity, yeah ♪
- Good morning. Good
morning. Good morning.
Good morning, before we
get even into the show,
grab the URL.
If you're watching on Twitter,
hit that retweet button,
grab the URL share on Facebook,
big shout out to LinkedIn.
You can share too.
There is a link you can see it,
Twitch Fam, I don't know
what you guys can do
but I know you can do something amazing,
and everybody's watching
on Instagram through live.
Big shout out, great to see you,
but Facebook share, share,
share, share, share.
A lot of love, a lot of good stuff.
Let's get into the comments,
Preston Bianchi good to see you,
Voiceover Donnie great to see you,
Green, good to see you.
Navine Segeway, good to see you.
Great to see you James Law.
I see the whole, whole crew in here.
Dustin, how you doing this morning?
Big shout out, Fosse.
- Very good.
- Good.
- Got some good sleep.
- Get some solid sleep?
- Yeah, yesterday I didn't
I had like one hour.
- What, day before?
- Yeah,
I just couldn't fall asleep
for some reason it was bad.
- You were playing
Pokemon and (indistinct)?
- Unfortunately, no (laughs).
- No? Fair enough.
All right, let's get in show.
Parker Snare.
One of the great gym teachers of all time.
- Hey Gary. Thanks for having me on here.
- Of course Paul, how are you?
- I'm doing awesome,
I appreciate your messaging
has helped me be a better dad,
a dentist and my company, Dental Nachos.
I have a special person, the
most important person to me,
I wanna to come on and say
thanks to you real quick.
- Please.
- Hey, Garyvee?
- How are you?
- Great, so nice to meet you.
- Nice to meet you as well.
- I'm Mary, otherwise known as Mrs. Nacho.
I just wanted to thank you
for being such an
inspiration to our company,
but also us personally, we
love your message on kindness
and you're are just awesome,
- Thank you.
- Thanks so much.
- Thank you so much.
I wish you well.
Thank you.
- thank you so much.
- Awesome, so Gary I
founded Dental Nachos.
Our Facebook group is 25,000 members.
Hopefully they're watching in.
Your patients can wait
guys, for five minutes.
So one of the things that
I have a challenge with
with dental nachos,
well first, I actually wanna thank you
for the best thing that happened,
during the pandemic about a year ago,
I was at the beach in New Jersey.
I'm a 42 year-old from New Jersey
and I signed up for your
community text platform.
I said, "I need this for Dental Nachos.
I see GaryVee has it.
Mark Cuban.
My favorite comedian
Sebastian Maniscalco."
But I made a little thing
for you here in Philly
and the movie Philadelphia
explained it to me
like I'm a four year old,
So gratitude, plus
patience, plus kindness,
plus document not produced equal success.
- I love it
- Because we were patient and a month ago,
we got approved for community.
So now I can communicate
with my Dental Nacho group, all the time.
So our community is built on
helping dentists make big life decisions
that dental school ignores.
How to buy a practice.
How to find your first job.
What I call the circle of dentisting life.
- Makes sense.
- Thanks, we built out this
platform a lot like Peloton.
In person, CD courses,
livestream and recorded.
But everything shut down
right now for in-person.
My challenge for you this morning,
I think is a tough one is, how
do I reach dentist in caves?
Dentistry is a cave profession.
Means we're isolated.
We're stressed.
We're in our own islands
and the 50-plus crew.
We have a Facebook page,
Instagram LinkedIn.
I even joined Tik Tok, all
these different platforms,
but how would you reach
the 50-plus audience
for Dental Nachos?
- I mean, it's email,
LinkedIn and Facebook.
- What's interesting about dentists
and the reason I'm on here,
always leave with gratitude,
is one of my sponsors
Iris was on the four DS, I was
walking around Philadelphia.
I said, "Hey, that's my sponsor."
and I just to show your
strategies pay off.
So they called me, you told them to bring
their dentist content
that had nothing to do with their product.
So they interviewed me and I said,
"You don't have to pay me,
but you just got to get
me an intro to GaryVee."
Mike Wong, I wanna thank
him for doing that.
But what's interesting about dentists,
thanks, is that they don't
really use a lot of like,
my dad was a dentist,
I worked with at least for 11 years
before he passed away, unfortunately.
He was an awesome dad, but he never really
used email or LinkedIn,
because dentists are
this craft profession.
- I get it, I get it.
I mean, look, if you can't read,
if someone's unreachable,
they're unreachable.
Like, you know, if you
need to do direct mail.
If you need to drive to their practices,
like that's just part of the game.
I would argue, that an enormous
percentage of dentists,
even the old school dentists,
are at least now on email.
- Right, I agree with you.
We had a Nacho delivery team
that went around Philadelphia
and surrounding areas
and would drop off Nachos
fun for the office,
because a lot of times their
team gets them involved.
- I would also argue that the 50 year-old
Doesn't need your service, the
way you pitched it as much.
Because, they could have
used it 25 years ago,
it probably would have been epic for them.
But I would argue that
Instagram and Tik Tok,
focusing on the 18 to 22 year old
in-school dentist is just a far,
a lot of times people,
overvalue someone they can't get
and undervalue the opportunity
on something they're getting.
- Got you.
Actually I agree with you.
- Do you see where I'm going?
Like it might take the same energy to get
one fucking 59 year old dentist,
as it does to get 88 dental students
and by the way that you positioned it,
at least by the way, I
just heard it, for me.
it makes so much sense
for a 21, 26, 19 year-old
dentist want-to-be to have
this be part of their life more
than the 57 year-old,
who's already kind of
like figured a lot of that out.
- It's a good I mean, well,
a lot of what we talk about (indistinct),
I heard you talk about
soft tissue yesterday
or the day before.
So we talked about developing
your core of your mind
how you speak, and your
clinical hand skills.
So that's really resonating
with people even before
dental school, but in this
circle of dentist in life,
the older dentist needs the babysitter,
they need the associate
or the dentist to come in
and work with them so they
can get more time off,
and that's leading some of the stress.
So I'm trying to figure
out a way to connect them.
- I mean, look, I think direct mail.
Print four or five page
pamphlet, with a huge URL,
I mean, even the most old
school can go to YouTube.
So I think if you say, look, text us
now that you've community,
text us at this,
like the front of the pamphlet,
I would have like a huge
phone number and say,
"Look, text us any
question we'll answer it.
Any question."
- Yeah.
I like that.
- You see where I'm going?
- Yeah.
- And then maybe
a very simple URL, like
maybe you get a URL like,
Nachodentsist.com/watch,
something or just something very simple.
Those two on the front
of four page pamphlet,
direct mail to their office,
I still think you can also
get a lot done on Facebook
and LinkedIn more than you would think.
- Well, we have that Facebook group
of 20,000 people (indistinct).
- That's very different
than running an ad
to 50 to 90 year-olds in
South Jersey Philly area,
with the ad being, "Do you
know anybody who's a dentist?
"Who's a 45 year-old dentist or older?"
And they're passing on that video,
that's a very different
execution than having a group.
- I like it, our Nacho
Stars, the 50 year-olds
that are in the group
are saying things like,
"I wish I had this when
I was a young dentist,
"maybe I can get one of them to start on
"that Facebook ad for me."
- Or, you can start a referral program,
where whatever the economics
are in your business,
you give a 25% lead gen fee,
- That's good, yeah.
- to the 50 year-olds,
and they just start getting
all their own friends.
- Dentists do like stuff like that,
I know my dentist people,
they will enjoy that, that's awesome.
One last thing, I, as
the leader of a company,
kind of working with
me, is like working with
a friendly tornado, I
have a lot of new ideas.
So how do you not overwhelm your team,
with too many new ideas,
while they're still working
on your existing ideas?
- By not judging them
when they're not executing
on certain ideas.
- They're gonna like hearing that.
They're watching it and
they're really gonna
enjoy hearing you say that.
- You know, I throw a ton of my team
and then three weeks later
recall something I threw at them,
and it hasn't even started,
and I have empathy, because I
know they're going super hard.
So it's, you continue with your ideas.
It's that you need to
make sure that you're not
burning them out and
judging them too much,
and I think you do that with kindness
when it hasn't started.
It's understanding, you know?
- One of our clips that you
did is, I changed my mind,
I changed my mind,
I play that all the time in Dental Nachos.
I say, "See, GaryVee does that."
So I preached this and I
had Mark Evans on GaryVee,
I sent him this shirt,
a Nacho shirt.
- I love it.
I love it.
- You have
at headquarters, you have at least
50 of these somewhere
- I will find it and rock it.
- that we sent you.
Go track one down.
- I will find one, yeah.
- so I really appreciate it
GaryVee, thanks so much.
- Take care, Paul.
- Thanks so much.
- All right, bye.
Let's keep going,
Some good information there,
hope everybody enjoyed that.
Lewis household, great to see you.
Mike Dreams, what's up with you?
Gary Glen, yes, I needed to hear that.
Thank you, you are welcome.
One of the great things
about Tea With GaryVee,
is how many the answers actually
resonate for people that are watching.
Let's also continue to
share, share, share.
Please share this on Facebook
and Twitter on the retweet,
or the share button on
LinkedIn Share button
or grab the URL and post it.
I wanna get some newbies
in here, newbies are fun.
Let's keep it moving.
- Hey, GaryVee. How's it going?
- I'm great, my friend, how
do you pronounce your name?
- Kaushal.
- Kaushal, it's such a pleasure,
- It's an honor to meet you, man.
I've been following you
for about six and a half,
seven years now (indistinct).
- Where are you from?
- I'm from Birmingham, Alabama.
I was born in New Orleans.
My parents from India, but
I was born in the States.
- Fantastic, what can I answer for you?
- So first of all, I obviously
do have some questions,
but more so than the questions,
the main reason I reached out was,
I really wanted to start
a relationship with you,
really wanted to just
build and get to really,
ultimately, you've impacted my life
more than you'll ever know.
So just being on the show and
being able to talk to you,
it means a lot to me.
- Thank you.
- It started off, I run
a social media agency.
We're a team of about 25 people,
I've been doing this
for about six years now.
We shifted to a social
media agency, back in 2016.
So I've been doing that
for about four years.
The name of the social
media agency is Socially
and we're based in Birmingham, Alabama.
So I've you know, talked to tons and tons
of members of your team.
Scott, who was actually
a member of Vayner,
back in the day as your CFO.
He was actually a mentor to us
on, still is a mentor to us,
and now I've talked with
James in the Sasha group,
we even work with Jesse out
of (indistinct) Chattanooga.
I've just been around your
circle for a very long time.
But one of the main things
at the social media agency,
that we've had issues with is,
we've had opportunities to talk to,
Fortune 500 clients, Fortune 100 clients.
But for some reason,
we just can't get past
a certain barrier,
whether it's they look at
us as a too small of a shop.
Whether we don't have the
recognition, we don't go out there
and win the awards that
these big agencies do,
and since we focus strictly on social,
we produce content we
know what to influence,
management platforms,
community management,
run ads, all that, but
we will only do social.
We don't dabble into
the whole digital space,
and I think sometimes that
shies away from big brands.
So that's an issue we've been having,
as far as like getting
in front of the door,
or getting even the introduction.
- And is, a couple things.
One, the market absolutely has evolved.
When I started selling social in 2009,
I didn't even know what it was.
So the thought of somebody
to being a specialty.
I think one of the ways to
think about big brands is,
there's a term in big
brands called orphan brands.
Small brands that they give no money to,
They're usually big
brands that we all know,
but they're just a Procter
or Unilever or Pepsi.
They're like 18th biggest brand,
which is like a huge root
beer or that we all know.
Or a huge pasta sauce, we all know.
But small in their world.
Hundreds of millions of dollars in sales,
not billions, 50 million.
I think that's a place
where you could win a scope.
So I think getting educated
on that part of the portfolio,
and then when you go in for the pitch,
you solely focus on that.
You're not getting Pepsi.
You're not getting Coke right now.
Just not where it's at.
So I think you'd go there.
Then also think about,
look, take it from somebody
who does business with
like Vayner and Sasha.
There's a lot of great things
to be focused on the small and mid-market.
You know, clients, and
I think sometimes ego,
is what drives people to
wanna do the big brands.
The budgets are bigger,
but the profit isn't necessarily bigger.
The vulnerability is enormous,
when you get fired from a big brand,
sometimes it's an enormous
percentage of your business.
So I would focus on orphan brands,
I would also, you know, and I did this.
I would also consider doing it for free.
- We've pitched that hundred percent,
you never watched it a long time.
So we've done it even produce free content
We had this concept of where
we literally pitch ideas of,
we did this for Dick's Sporting Goods,
because they used to
be one of our clients.
So we would just pitch a content buffets,
a bunch of different ideas.
We don't price them in whatever they like,
we'll do it for them at a
price that we negotiate.
- I think the other thing you focus on,
is you take advantage
of where you're located.
I think I really focus
on southeast, Midwest.
Like, I think you play in the middle.
I would really focus on
those middle companies,
Minnesota, even Chicago,
definitely companies
that are in Nashville.
I would really focus on
those companies, as well.
- Okay, so we've done,
one thing that I wanna
mention is close outside of,
Socially in a part of Socially,
which will lead to my second question is,
we've started a event business
where we actually have a
social media event once a year.
It's called the Southern Social Summit.
So we, it's in Birmingham.
It's gonna be in Atlanta eventually,
because we're moving to Atlanta.
But essentially, it's a
event around social media,
just educating the community about how,
what they can be doing on social media,
how they can help their business.
Even if you're a freelancer,
what they can be doing to help
their freelancing business
and just really educational.
We won't make much money out of it.
but we just wanna promote people.
We had about 500 people last year.
This year, it will be digital,
obviously, because of COVID.
So we're expecting it to be a lot bigger.
So outside of that, the
second question I had was,
an idea that we had was, we
wanna do a staffing agency
strictly around social media jobs.
- Smart.
- Obviously to tailor
potential client.
- Yeah, smart.
A lot of people want, yeah smart.
I like that idea.
We think a lot about being a recruiting.
I'm surprised I haven't launched it yet.
I mean, people just
desperately need better talent.
So, I think there's something there.
- Okay, because I saw it from
one of some of your intern program,
where they would get other jobs
at major agencies.
- 100%, I mean.
- Yeah, and I was just
like, that's amazing
and the empathy that you had to show like,
"I built this person, they
showed them what they got
"and they're able to go out
there and do what they love."
That's amazing, yep.
One last thing, I know you have
a bunch of people to talk to.
That leads me to one last
thing, about things that I love.
The main thing that I really wanted to
talk to you about was,
one thing you talked
about on your content was
people that make very little money,
50 to $60,000, but they're really happy
and they're able to show that.
- By the way, 50 to $60,000,
is not very little money
and I know where you're going.
this is not a razzes
more of a conversation.
it's that that I'm focused on.
Which is, everybody thinks
about a millionaire.
Everybody thinks bottom up kind of
doing something's 100,000,
when the medium incomes 40,000,
you know, like, so like,
you know, yeah, I'm
fascinated about happiness.
But go ahead, I'm sorry.
- So I put out content obviously,
it's not as much as you say.
So you're looking at my social
media, publish it on me.
But ultimately, when I
put out this happiness,
I'm showing them I do right now,
I preach about how happy I am.
I don't have tons and tons of
money in the value of society,
or what society thinks is success.
But ultimately, my happiness is success
and I put that up there.
But how can people how can
and maybe they don't need to listen,
but how can I make them listen,
or show them that outside
of just saying happiness?
Is it that's what really matters?
- 99.9999% of the world
doesn't listen to me.
That's your answer.
It's not about making people listen
is more of a subconscious, selfish act.
It's like you do the right thing,
somebody on Twitch has
said, "This is really cool
that GaryVee is doing this with his time."
Like, you do the right thing
and you just move right
like, I get it and I, listen.
I like people being selfish,
They should care about
themselves and their family.
I also think sometimes,
it's really great to just,
it's kind of like, of
course, all lives matter.
But let's focus on black lives.
Of course, we should be
selfless and be kind people,
but it's okay sometimes to be selfish.
It's okay sometimes to be 100% selfless.
One of the things I think
that really works for me
is when I make my content,
I'm in completely the
mindset of selflessness.
You know, so many people are like,
"What are you doing with
Tea With Gary, you know,
get ready to Tea With GaryVee,
what's the strategy there
like, to help people?"
To bring value to like COVID, it's heavy.
The times are heavy.
Coming in the morning,
to me, nine to 10 a.m.
is the worst time like the day is started.
I feel anxiety.
I also know it's a great
time for a lot of people,
because it gives them that pep.
That reinforcement.
- Last question,
because I know the first two
were a little bit selfish
in running my business,
but ultimately, I was also
thinking how can I help
the audience that's watching?
- By doing it, by doing it.
Just do it, Just do it.
Appreciate you brother.
- I love you, Gary.
- Talk to you soon, I love you back.
Stay well.
- All right, you too.
- I love some of these.
Dustin, I literally slept
10 hours last night.
- Jealous.
- Somebody, in the comments was like,
"You look tired, Gary."
I'm like, "Man, because everybody thinks
I'm a big fan of sleep."
But I talk a lot about going
hard while you're awake,
but I always think about like DNA.
Like, I've got the hardcore
Eastern European like,
no matter how, like even when
I was like, 19 like the bag,
they go under my eyes that I always like,
and my skincare routine is all time worst.
I think I've like, washed my face once.
So like yeah, it's just really funny,
because when I see that stuff I'm like,
"Wait to see what",
because my uncle, my grandfather pictures,
I'm like, "Wait, do
you see me in 10 years.
Like 90."
(laughing)
Keep going,
- What up?
- What up, Kristin?
- What's up Gary?
- What's going on?
It's so funny,
because I have like a whole gang of people
watching because I've been
like manifesting this moment
for like the past couple months
and tell my friends every day like,
"Yeah, we turned it on
to you with GaryVee."
So they're all like watching today.
So you're excited about the newbie,
so like there's a whole gang of people
that are like,
- That's good.
- trying to be here today.
- So I have a couple
questions just two quick ones,
if that's okay.
So a little backstory, when I was 20,
I kind of dropped out of college
and then I got pregnant with my son.
Me and a few of my friends,
I asked them if they like
wanted to start this mom group
and so we kind of started
this mom group and turned it
into a nonprofit and
it like really blew up,
and it was like this amazing
thing and a lot of fun
and probably still one of
my greatest accomplishments,
and COVID kind of took that
and like, put it to a halt.
Like, we couldn't meet,
we couldn't do anything.
And I actually I guess,
in that time period,
so over the last couple months,
I kind of found a new passion.
So I started doing like, DIY projects,
and furniture flips and stuff like that.
So I ended up-
(indistinct)
Yeah, yeah (laughs).
So, it's been really cool
and like people are like really into it.
So like, I don't know, I
guess I kind of feel bad
about abandoning my old passion,
but also-
- You can't apologize
for the truth.
- True that, true that (laughs).
It was kind of becoming more like a chore,
rather than something that I
was like more excited to do.
- And by the way,
not everything in life
has to be so absolute.
That's like the biggest problem
right now in our society.
Everything's like,
"You're bad, you're good."
Everything's so binary,
and there's like no room for
like a little compromise,
and that's what I think about
your situation right now.
You don't have to completely
bounce on the moms group.
You could just turn it into
something that you check in
once a month on, or it's an
every six week thing now,
instead of an everyday thing.
- That is true.
We do run like a private
group that's still up
and people still like can get
advice and things like that.
- And you can make a video
and copy here and say,
or write it right in there.
I don't know how its
structured and be like,
"Yo, listen. I'm evolving, this
is what I'm about right now,
"but this is forever, something I love,
"and I'm gonna come here every six weeks
"and I'm gonna hang for
three hours and anything
that I was bringing to the table before,
"if I could bring during
that time we're good."
- True that, true that (laughs).
So to expand a little bit more on that.
Like, I guess like my
personality as a whole is like
I'm kind of a giver, so I
feel like, give, give, give
like constantly and I feel
like you're a giver too
how do you, because like I
give my all at work all day.
I come home I have two kids,
so I give my all to them
my friends, my family
just constantly and then
after they go to bed I'm
trying to like work on this
like new passion and like
how do you find the balance?
Because I know that
you're like a giver too.
Like how do you pour from an empty cup,
like at the end of the day?
- It's not empty, because
then it's probably
this is what works for you too,
like the giving is your energy, right?
Like when I give I feel alive,
and when I give I don't
expect anything in return,
So I'm rarely disappointed
from the giving.
Then I think the last
layer of that cake is
I don't judge myself.
Like if I go three months and
I wanna get something done
and it's not progressing,
because I've got nothing in the cup,
because I gave too much
over the last 100 days,
then that's okay.
But it's happening a lot to me right now,
between the business and
making sure family and friends,
are okay and between the all in challenge
where we raised almost $60,000,000,
and between, you know, just,
there's just so you know,
being there for so many friends
that are really struggling right now,
so many friends, contemporaries
and acquaintances
are struggling, just heavy, right?
Like yesterday, there was a
report about like the pig flu
in China and just like, some
of my friends were just like,
"I give up."
I'm like, "Okay, relax, you know?"
Like, when you're the emotional strength
for a lot of people, it's daunting.
So what ends up happening is,
if I didn't get this something
over the last three weeks,
six weeks, that I needed to
financially, professionally,
emotionally, I just know it's okay.
I think a lot of people
beat themselves up like,
I could see you being like,
"Damn, I didn't register my
daughter for camp, I fucked up."
Or, "Shit like you know?"
I'm kind of like just trying out here.
I think it's self-love
and it's being practical about
when you're giving all day,
sometimes something's gonna drop.
I think balance is in
the eye of the beholder.
everyone's like, "Gotta get
that work life balance down."
I'm like, "That's individual."
everyone's got a different point of view
on work life balance is.
and I'm all over the place, right?
Like, last night, I slept 10 hours.
We could go on last week, I'd stayed up
to two o'clock in the morning
and looked up sports cards
and woke up at six.
I just don't think life is as
binary as people think it is,
and I'm just comfortable
navigating it, you know?
- For sure.
Okay, so then my other question.
So I've been into
flipping and all of that.
So I started a page called,
like This Simple Flipping Life.
This is supposed to be about
like, minimalism and then like,
taking what you have
and kind of flipping it
and DIY renovations and things like that.
But, I already kind of like
naturally had like a little bit
of a following, like on my personal pages.
and so like I was kind
of torn between should I
just like do it on my personal pages?
- I'm a fan of that.
- Okay, I was like, "I don't know",
'cause I don't know if I should.
Okay so like my end goal,
is to like flip houses
and to show people how to flip houses.
Like I don't know if I should
build a brand around that too.
Or like just-
- Rebrand it.
- Kristin, the brand is you.
Look at your handle.
"Life as Kristin."
Life is one fucking dimension.
You already got the fucking,
you already got the name.
I'm putting out wine,
I'm putting out sports cards,
I'm putting out business,
I'm putting out garage sales,
I'm putting out all sorts of
shit on my platform, people.
People really think it's a niche game.
I don't.
I mean, everyone's got a
different point of view,
but like, I don't see it that way.
You know, I really don't.
I think I mix it all
and some people are like
and people are like,
listen when I went from,
can you imagine this?
When I started talking
about business on my page,
after I did wine content for three years,
before I did any business content.
Everybody was just yelling at me like,
"Yo, stay in your lane wine boy.
You're not, don't talk about business."
Like people just, "You know,
like, this isn't gonna work.
You're gonna fail, like
stick to what you know."
I was laughing I'm like,
"You don't know me.
I know a ton of shit."
And you know a ton of shit.
You're gonna have different interests,
because I can tell the way you're talking,
and that's fucking amazing.
That's what makes it interesting.
- Thank you, thank you.
People that were hating in the comments
are probably still hating (laughs).
- Listen, hate is the
bi-product of somebody
who's unhappy with their own life.
We should stop hating our haters,
we should start loving our haters.
I mean, I have a crazy relationship
with the people that hate me.
I actually have incredible
amounts of compassion
and sympathy, and
empathy, like the thought
to take time out of my day to try to
drag somebody else down
or make them feel bad,
that blows my mind.
I've got zero seconds for that shit.
Like, I'm trying to
spend every second I can
to make people happy and feel good,
I can't even imagine the deep insecurity,
the bad parenting, the
unlucky circumstances.
The pain, I mean, to really
want to go to somebody
to really want to go to
somebody's fucking account,
and try to make them feel awful too,
and notice how the key word there was too.
- Yeah.
- There's nobody who's happy and content,
who's going into the comments hating.
We're gonna need to find
a way to be compassionate,
I see people blocking and deleting hate.
Don't block and delete.
That's your own insecurity,
of you are not been able
to deal with something
that might be making
you feel uncomfortable.
I mean, this is about
going to a higher place.
I roll with deep compassion for my haters.
You have time to worry about my life,
when I don't even know your name?
That's not good, I want
it to be better for you.
- They say if you don't have any haters
then you're not doing
something right too, so
(laughs).
- But that's again,
that's street talk
to like pump someone up.
I'm coming at it from love talk.
I'm coming at this from a
totally different place.
I don't need haters or cheers
to tell me I'm winning.
I know I'm winning.
I don't need any fucking validation from
the outside, pro or con.
I'm actually talking about genuinely,
genuinely caring about other human beings,
especially the ones that
are most trying to hurt you.
That's on some different mental shit.
That is what I think is
the next step that we need.
- I agree.
Can I get a follow too?
- Hell yeah!
- My fiance was like,
"He's not gonna follow you.
Gary's only gonna follow me."
(laughs)
- What's his name?
- His name is Branton.
Tell him he's a hater.
- What's his name?
- Branton.
- Branton? You lost this one bro,
you lost this one.
(laughing)
- Thanks, bro.
- I got you.
Man, you got a real page going.
Good for you.
- That was like I just started trying too.
Like that was naturally just my page.
Literally, I probably
posted like five times
in like the past few days,
because I knew I was
gonna be on here (laughs).
So I was like, "I have
to get it together",
but the rest of that
is literally just like,
I literally just started trying.
My bio says, "GaryVee made me do it too."
- (laughs) I love it, I love it.
I wish you well, take care.
- Thank you.
- Bye, bye.
- [Kristin] Bye.
- Man, that was a good
little moment there.
I've been really thinking
a lot about this.
There's so much anxiety and
hate, right now in the world.
We're on tilt.
People are just looking to fight,
looking to tear down,
looking to blame somebody.
It's a real, real, real heavy time
and there is only one answer, only,
which is compassion an empathy.
You know, that doesn't mean that
there aren't systematic
things that need to change
and things of that nature,
but people are selling fear,
or they're selling judgment.
Right now everything is fear or judgment
and fear or shame, excuse me.
It's fear or shame, right now.
It's fucking fear or shame.
Just not working.
Let's keep it moving.
- Hello, hey there a
GaryVee, good morning.
- Hey, Brandon, how are you?
- Pretty, good, pretty good.
Truly grateful for you offering me
these interactions and experiences, man.
There's so much uncertainty,
in these transitional times
of self-growth and I have
gained so much insight,
potent motivation and
value from your content,
so thank you very much.
- Got you.
- Awesome, I'm gonna ask
you just one question.
As a 35 year-old, departing a life of
hospitality and restaurants.
I'm inspired to sort of like
sample the waters, as you say,
to a lot of 20 year-olds,
and I'm asking how do I
negotiate the feelings that,
I don't have enough time
to try these new things out
that I need to fast track my progress
with boot camps and certifications?
Sort of to compensate for lost time
and need to make a
decision like immediately.
- No.
(laughing)
You're wrong.
- It's good to hear (laughs).
- At 34 years-old, I
started my life all over
and had nothing.
You know, a lot of people are
very confused by my story.
I came into my dad's business.
I worked my fucking
face off, from 22 to 34.
I built that from a three to
a 60,000,000 business, me.
I never got paid more than 100K,
because in family businesses,
you just kind of put all the
money back in the business.
Then I left at 34 and had dick,
because it was my mission
to give back to my parents.
I was proud to build that
business for my parents,
but I left, I had nothing.
I love when people try to throw hate
like the last thing, like, "Fuck this guy.
His dad gave him $3,000,000."
No, no. My dad had a
business doing $3,000,000.
Top line revenue, not profit.
I fucking went in there
and built it for 12 years.
Left with zero and at 34,
started VaynerMedia with AJ,
six months before my 35th birthday
and had no money, to the point
where I had to get a friend,
big shout out Mike
Lazerow from Buddy Media,
to let our office be in one
of his conference rooms,
because we couldn't afford rent.
- Huh, crazy, okay so-
- Okay, now just to put
the full clarity for everybody,
because I was making 40, 60,
70, 80,000 a year in my 20s
and I lived what I give advice on.
I saved my money.
I had a dog-shit fucking car
I had dog-shit clothes.
I didn't go out.
I didn't do shit.
I saved.
So then at 32, when Facebook and Twitter
and Tumblr came along, I was able to take
the money and put it all in that.
Bet the farm on it, which
is why I had no money.
I was saving.
But then right before we
started Vayner, a year earlier,
I put all that money to
work on this big risk
I was taking that everybody
said I was crazy on,
on Facebook, Tumblr and Twitter
that obviously worked out.
So I ate dog-shit for a decade,
which gave me the savings.
I lived that $65,000
a year life, you know,
and then I put it to work,
and I made the right bet.
- Gotcha.
- The point of that story
is really to tell you
that like I basically started over at 34.
- Okay, yeah.
- So when I hear people like worried at 26
and worried at, now I
came with my experience.
I have the experience of
learning how to build a business,
because I fucking had talent.
But most people that have my
kind of talent from 22 to 34,
they're named fucking LeBron
James and they make billions.
Like, you know, or they're
like, one of the founders
of a company that sold a ton of business,
I did it for the family.
I lived my truth.
I don't regret it.
At the time, you know, in my early 30s,
there was some resentment, you know.
But, the reality is now it's
the best thing I ever did.
I did the right thing by my folks.
I did the right thing for my soul.
I'm proud of how I did it.
Now it allows me to tell
you right at this moment,
(knocking)
you're a child, bro.
- Cool, man.
- What are we
talking about here, bro?
You're a kid.
- Yeah.
- Don't compare.
When I was 27 years old and
working the Christmas season,
I had to be on the floor of the store,
because usually, I would
be downstairs or upstairs,
once we built a new store
and be on the computer selling wine.
But during December,
I had to go downstairs
because it was too busy.
My friends would come, that
I went to high school with,
would come to the liquor
store, the wine store,
and they would buy a case of champagne
and I would ring them up
at the cash register, cashier
and then I would grab the
case and take it outside
and put it into their car.
Their BMW sometimes,
because some of my friends
were good students and kind of went to
Wall Street or did some shit.
When I tell you there was never a moment,
in that entire story I've just told you.
Think about the humility
and patience and competence
that is needed to be the stock boy,
be the cashier and be the servant
that brings out the box to
your high school friend's car
and not envy it,
but use it as motivation,
as inspiration, as focus.
So don't worry about what
some 23 year-old's doing.
That has nothing to do with you.
That was the biggest
problem of everyone getting
so hyped on Zucks or Kevin Systrom,
or Travis with Uber, Instagram, Facebook.
They were incredible entrepreneurs
and did transcendent stuff,
but they're like had
nothing to do with you.
That's the problem with
like the prior conversation
where the wonderful young gentlemen said,
very little money, 50, 60,000.
50, 60,000, people rip their arms off for.
Half the people here, watching right now,
more maybe, would die to
make 50 60,000 a year, right?
But-
- Yeah, absolutely.
- Because if they're making
58 and they don't like it,
is it better to make 42 and love it?
Like you know, to me, that's
just the whole game, man.
Listen, I'm at the top of my game,
well on my way to all time stuff,
and I'm like sitting here
debating if I wanna retire
and be like quit everything
and just become a baseball card dealer.
(laughing)
I'm being
dead fucking serious.
If I didn't love Vayner
and GaryVee so much,
doing all this stuff and
I'm still like having
weird thoughts this week.
- Gotcha.
- Like I'm saying
on some like real talk.
- Gotcha, I'm hearing all of that man.
I really appreciate that
you're saying it's okay
to just let that allow that leg room
to happen in your 30s because
(indistinct).
- Because the 30s
are early bro.
- Yeah
- I feel young as shit at 44.
- Yeah, I don't know what the pressure is
in the 30s game or something,
it's a phase-
- I will tell you
what the pressure is.
The pressure is society made rules.
Your parents your friend,
your 36 year-old good
friend from fifth grade
who's on kid number three
and has a second house like,
the pressures is envy and
caring about other people,
instead of focusing on your own shit.
- Cool, cool.
- It's the Joneses.
- Yeah, yeah (laughs) I
hear you man, awesome.
I really appreciate that,
thank you so much, Gary.
- Talk to see,
- Awesome.
- Really appreciate you bro, good luck.
- Thank you so much.
- Dustin?
- Yes sir.
- There's some real shit,
can you get the team to
clip some of the shit
and put it on the gram?
- Trying (laughs).
- Fucking killing it out here.
(laughing)
Fuck, let's go.
I am on a roll.
Said, "Gary's on a roll."
That's right!
Let's keep it moving.
- Okay.
- What's up, Gary?
Oh shit man, I'm fucking nervous, man
(laughs).
- Don't worry bro,
we're friends.
- Like shaking and everything.
I've been watching you for
like three years, dude.
Damn, can't even get the
nerves in check right now.
- Where do you live?
- Naples Florida, actually.
- I love it.
- My wife is watching, my
mom is probably watching too.
So what's up, guys?
- Awesome.
- They know this is like a
really big deal to me, man.
Like I said I've been watching
you for like three years.
Damn, holy shit.
- Don't worry about it, bro.
- I'm trying to be a man ,try
to be a man here (laughs).
- Bro, it doesn't take a man.
a man owns his emotions.
I'm a man out here
talking about compassion,
sympathy, kindness and love.
So, I'm proud of you for
talking about your nerves.
I'm an unbeliever, I just
want you to hear this clear,
you can't imagine how
nice that makes me feel,
I'm super flattered.
- Awesome, I'm so glad, man.
- It's humbling.
- You really do change
people's lives dude,
like, I'm sure you know,
but it's like to a whole different level.
- Thank you, bro.
- So I started watching
like three years ago, actually,
I was like in tech school.
To give you kind of a quick backstory,
I'm trying to be as quick as I can.
I'm 22, I'm married.
I've been married for like three years.
I just had a baby like, you know, January.
- Congrats.
- So you know, I'm pretty
fulfilled, in that sense.
You know what I'm saying?
But I'm like, I'm
aspiring like I one thing
I've always loved to do,
since I've been like 13,
is like make YouTube videos
just because like, I have
had rough patches in my life
when I was younger,
and like watching people on YouTube,
like, you know, entertaining people,
like that's always been like,
I'm like, wow, like, you know,
it's always made me feel good.
So I've like always, like, I
wanna do that for people too,
and like, my thing is like,
I love cars like I like racing.
I like building race cars and shit.
So I have a YouTube channel,
that it's been out for, like four years.
But I've been so inconsistent.
I upload and then I delete it,
because I think the
videos aren't good enough,
just like really negative.
Then that's when I started watching you.
Actually, like I said, three years ago,
I was in tech school.
I think I really went to tech school too
because of like, I was like,
"I need to make a normal
life out of myself."
I was already engaged,
about to get married.
I'm like, "I need a real
career this and that."
But then I started watching you
I'm like, "Man, knows his shit."
(laughing)
Like I'm just
doing this because, I
think that's what I need,
but it really doesn't.
- Just for clarity for,
As long as every if there's
some new people watching,
that's slang term in our world of like,
we're doing it the wrong way.
I think a lot of times when
some of the Jersey jargon comes
out of my mouth, like,
I don't want people to like
think we're demonizing here
like it just means like we're
there's more opportunity.
So keep going.
- Right, yeah.
I was like, "I'm doing all this
I feel like for other people."
Because, I was like the
bad kid growing up, man.
I'm telling you I was like
the black sheep of the family.
I was bad behaved,
terrible grades in school.
I'd throw my report card away,
before I gave it to my mom.
Oh shit, my phone (laughs).
- I literally flushed down
the toilet my report card
all the time, it was a funny
game between me and my mom.
- Oh sorry.
- She knew,
but I was trying to buy it,
it was because I would always get punished
for usually a month, but
my mom would let me off
after two weeks, so it was always trying
to buy an extra weekend
before it's so funny.
- Oh, of course, man.
Like I was just like,
I basically like I feel
like I went to tech school
and I did all that just to prove myself,
just kind of be like, I'm
not as bad as people think,
especially when your
family says you're bad.
It's kind of rough to
deal with that, you know?
- It's extremely difficult.
It's really tough.
- Yeah, so I was like, I'm gonna do this.
I graduated with a 4.0,
which I know in tech schools
like now, it's only a year and a half.
So it's not like too big of a deal.
I tried to do my best.
- Bro don't
undermine your success.
- Yeah, I know, just some
people like I'm sure like,
"Oh, that's not hard."
- the biggest issue out of your mouth
is the words "some people."
- Yeah.
- Bro, you have to stop
giving a fuck about
these people in the comments,
and the ones that are watching.
- Yeah, that's true.
- Ready for this?
Let me tell you about my life.
Some people thought business,
like selling sports cards
as a teenager was gonna
lead to me being a bum,
because I got bad grades.
Those some people were wrong.
- Yeah, they're definitely wrong.
I mean (laughs).
- Some people are right.
Some people are wrong,
but value like, I always
listen very carefully,
and just like you hedging 4.0,
based on some people,
is the biggest thing we need to work on
in the next 91 years of your life.
You've gone nine, like, that's just,
that's where you're
at, we got to fix that.
When I say fix that, that feels too heavy.
You need to get into a better
relationship with that.
Everyone's always gonna have an opinion.
- Yeah, I mean, no that's 100% true.
Everyone always has something to say.
- I thought Patrick Mahomes
was not gonna be good quarterback.
- Right.
- I don't know.
Football doesn't seem like a whole lot,
but guess what?
He's really good.
- Yeah, well, like that was
like, all that basically,
just to kind of lead up to
what I think about myself,
like in the sense of.
So like, I'm a very negative person.
You know what I'm saying?
Like, I'm a Negative Nancy kind of guy.
Literally when I wake up
in the morning-
- You're cynical,
like you wake up and you're cynical.
- Yes, Like I wake up and I'm like,
"What can go wrong today,
because like, I've tried so hard."
- You're not, ready for this?
You're not a negative person,
you're scared person.
- Yeah, I could definitely.
- Alexis, that's a big difference, bro.
For all the people out
there that are watching
that are fear that are scared
and fear-based and vulnerable.
You're not negative.
Don't demonize yourself.
You're actually vulnerable.
You're not negative, bro.
- I didn't think about
it like that, actually.
I never thought like-
- That's why
we're fucking doing Tea With GaryVee!
- Yes, that's all I'm glad to be on here
because I needed tea-
- Let me tell you why
this is important, Alexis.
If you, all of a sudden,
when you wake up tomorrow
and you realize you're not a negative,
when somebody thinks
they're a negative person,
that's devastating,
you're like, "I'm bad."
No, you're not bad, you're hurt.
- Yeah, maybe it was
something that happened to me,
when I was younger or
something, just kind of like,
- Of course!
- where it's like,
"What's gonna happen today?"
It's such a bad, but I
feel like that affects me
with everything I do.
Because like,
- Of course it does!
- when I'm making
YouTube videos, or like when
I'm doing stuff like that,
I'm kind of like, "Oh,
this is gonna be trash.
Like, this isn't good enough."
You know it just like, I don't know,
I put myself down a
lot, and I'm just like,
my original question
actually is nothing with
what we're talking about, you know, but.
- Bro, this is the real
shit and like we're here
I'm with you right now I
like this talk right now
I really, really, really
I think you helping
over the next 10 years,
because a lot of people watch this video,
not when we record it,
you're about to help a lot of people
I can see in the comments.
You literally just helped a lot of people
just in that one moment,
So let's keep going.
I'm telling you that your
self esteem is vulnerable,
because to your point,
you said it earlier, when
your family tells you
you're not good, you believe that shit.
- Yeah, yeah 100%.
100% and I think-
- We need to get out of that.
- I know.
- And does your family still say that?
- I honestly, so like as soon as I started
watching your videos,
and I know you say not to do this as much,
but like I feel like you know,
I just tried to cut out
negative people out of my life
and just isolate myself.
Like I do this a lot even like,
I've actually never had
any long term friends.
Like I've never had a
friend that I can be like,
"Oh, I've been best friends
with this guy for a long time."
I think my best friend right now,
I guess is like, I've
known him for like a year.
You know what I'm saying?
Because like, as soon as
someone does something,
- Listen.
- like makes me feel negative,
I just kind of like isolate
myself and I push everyone away.
You know what I'm saying, like.
- Of course, because
you're emotionally soft.
- Yeah, yeah I can see that.
- And your Mendoza line
for cutting someone off
is super low.
Like for me, my Mendoza
line is super high.
Like you have to really,
really, really go somewhere.
and I've had a lot of things done to me.
I had a friend in college
who stole my Sega Genesis,
and I still was friends
with him after I found out.
- Holy shit.
- Because I knew
he was in a bad spot to do that to me.
I was at a rugged college,
but like but other people
I know cut people off
because they said something.
Like, the reason you don't
have long-term friendships,
is because of your own lack of self-esteem
and your inability to rise
above when somebody goes low.
- Right, and like
that was gonna be-
- Keep going,
- Oh, I was just gonna say like,
that was gonna be my thing.
Like I said, I've been
watching you for a long time
and I know like, you actually
I was worse than that, to be honest.
Like, watching you
- Really?
- has made me better,
like, you know, more confident
myself and more like,
I can deal with that kind of stuff more.
But I feel like it takes a long time too.
Because even in three
years of watching you,
like I'm still not where I wanna be,
if that makes any sense.
Like I'm still, not like mentally where
I wanna be and just stop being so negative
and I wish and every time
something good happens in my life,
I'm always like, "Okay,
what's gonna happen now?"
Like, you can ask my wife
like, I don't get excited
when good things happen,
because I automatically
think something bad's
gonna happen right after.
- Bro, I live with this my father's
got a lot of these similar traits, bro.
- Holy shit, so.
- I understand you.
- Is there any way like I can, you know,
like get better at that?
- Of course!
You just said you got
better the last three years.
- Yeah, yeah I feel like I have.
I feel like I've gotten better at like,
stop fearing about what
other people think about me.
That's like a big thing for me,
like I've gotten way better at that.
- You know, you see how
you've got some muscle?
- Yeah (laughs).
- How'd you do that?
- Oh, yeah, I worked out.
Played football in high school, yeah.
- That's how you do this.
Listening to positivity,
owning your shortcomings.
Accept that you're the reason
I'm talking with such candor here,
I'm sure some people are watching like,
"Damn Gary's, like, exposing his shit."
I'm not doing it.
- I like it, I love it, It's awesome.
- 'Cause it's empowering when
you own your shortcomings.
I don't wanna say that
I thought Patrick Mahomes,
I mean, it's a silly one,
but I don't wanna say that.
I thought Patrick Mahomes was gonna
throw too many pigs to
be a good quarterback.
He might end up being the best quarterback
in football history if
keeps going at this pace.
Like you know, but if you can't own
your fucking shortcomings,
well then you can't talk
about your strengths.
Bro, I actually you know,
what I think is keeping me here with you
is my deep belief that you're on your way,
because it's about awareness.
The fact that you have the
strength to come on here
with all these people watching
and talk to me like this,
actually makes me believe
that you're well on your way,
because I know a lot of people who don't.
- Yeah, I'm just like, trying
to like, it's such a bad thing
in my life that like,
it's like a mental block
for everything I do that it's like, man,
I need to stop doing this.
It's like I realized, I'm so you know,
and like, just trying to like stop it.
- You need to realize that you're not bad.
You grew up being told you
were bad and you believed it.
You need to realize you're
not bad, you're scared.
The second you go from, "I'm a bad guy,
"I'm a tough guy, I'm a negative guy",
to, "I'm a soft guy, I'm a vulnerable guy,
I'm emotionally, like not
where I need to be guy",
all of a sudden the way you
even look at yourself changes
and then you could start focusing on
building those muscles on that.
You know, do you get this
feeling that you cut people off,
because you don't feel like
you get into this place where
you feel like they're
pulling one off on you
and you don't like that?
- Yes, like, I always think
somebody has an angle.
Every time someone's nice to me,
I'm like, "Okay, what's your angle, dude?
Like, what do you want from me?"
You know what I'm saying?
- Did you feel that way
about me the first time
you saw the content, potentially?
Like, "What's gonna be the other shoe?
Like, is he gonna try to sell me a course?
Or what's the fucking punchline?"
- Actually-
- Or do you not remember?
- Surprisingly, I feel like
I didn't just because like,
you were so honest that I feel like
you wouldn't be the type to do that.
You know what I'm saying?
Like, you were just
being like, straight up,
like authentic and honest.
- And so it just worked for you.
Okay so-
- It really did.
- I think and maybe that's
because I was remote
and through right screen
and stuff, like,
- Possibly, possibly.
- You know, look, I think you need to,
here's where I'm trying to get you to go.
You need to get into a
totally different place
with your self esteem.
You need to love yourself.
That's why the biggest moment of this talk
was you're not negative,
you're just vulnerable.
That was the biggest moment,
because when you wake up,
and you're like, "I'm scared today,
"and I need to get less scared today",
that is huge, huge compared
to waking up and saying,
"I'm negative, I'm a bad guy."
That's a game changer, Alexa.
that's a game changer.
- Yeah, it's like hard though.
Like I tried to I really, really
like there's a lot of times
where I'm like, "Okay, like
just stop thinking like that,
you know, like, you got this oh."
- You have to understand
it's ingrained in you.
So what you need to do is practice.
What do I mean by that?
The next, this one friend
you got right now for a year,
the first time he does something that
doesn't pop off properly.
You have to fucking, you
have to like email me,
or DM me, or watch this video again.
You have to forgive him.
- Right? Yeah, that's not
hold grudges (laughs).
- Bro, grudges are garbage.
Grudges are fucking garbage.
Grudges are the execution of a weak man.
- Yeah, no I agree 100%.
It makes you just, you know,
makes your life quality go down,
when you hold grudges,
because you can't just pull it out.
- Is your wife positive?
- Yes, She's like the
complete opposite of me.
Yeah, like, I feel like I try
to bring her down a little.
Like, I'm that bad.
- Of course you do!
- That I try to bring her.
- You're not that bad.
You're not that bad, bro.
I'm telling you right now,
if we change the terminology in your life,
shit, we'll get good.
You're not that bad.
You're that weak.
You're that scared.
You're that soft.
- I totally agree with you honestly.
- Which is big, I wanna
change your vernacular,
because if you do, you'll
be a different man.
It's that when you're most scared,
you try to bring her down to your level.
- Yeah, it's exactly what I do,
that's what when you say
you talk about like haters,
like trying to bring other people down.
- Do you find you find
yourself like, being jealous of
like, another guy looks at her like,
are you trying to like cage her?
- No, not like that, actually.
Like, I'm not like bad like that,
but I'm bad in the sense of like,
when she's like, trying to
be happy for me for something
that I accomplish or positive
or she's like-
- You're like,
"Don't do that, because I'm gonna,
something's gonna happen and
then I'm gonna let you down
and then that's gonna
be like."
- Yes.
- That's my fear, like, let
my son down, let her down.
Like, I'm always like that.
- Bro, listen to me.
The only thing that you
can do to let them down,
is by continuing down the path
of thinking that you're bad.
- Right? Yeah, no, yeah, I can't,
I don't want him to grow up like that,
you know, like being like me.
like, I don't want him to.
- Of course you don't.
But let me tell you,
because I've watched this.
I've watched this transpire,
because I'm old for 44.
I got some real fucking emotional wisdom.
What's gonna end up happening
is, if your child or children
end up having similar DNA to you,
you're gonna feel so bad
that you're gonna actually resent them
and have like a worse relationship.
You'll have a good
relationship with the children
that take your wife's DNA,
and you'll have a bad relationship with
the children that take your DNA,
because it's gonna be painful to you,
because you're gonna be like,
"Fuck, I passed that on to her or him.
So I'm out."
You can't do that.
- No I agree with that.
- You can't do that.
- I know, okay, yeah.
- Bro, I'm really proud of you.
- Thank you.
- To be at this place,
at this young of an age to be
self-aware enough to know what's brewing,
and to have the courage to come on here
and talk to me about this shit.
that's game changing.
- Thank you.
- When I tell you,
you're close, because the only thing
that holds people back is hiding shit.
- Right, right.
- Right now, you just told
10s of thousands of people
about your shit.
- Yeah, yeah it's just
like that bad, dude.
I'm like, "I have to tell
someone that actually like",
because like, I tell
other people like my wife,
I wanna tell the people
I mean, like my wife,
and I'm like, she's just like,
I feel like maybe hearing
it from her is not as
good because I'm like, "Oh, of course,
you're just gonna try to like, bring me up
and make me feel better
because I'm your husband."
So of course, I feel like her answer
is not as genuine maybe,
but it probably is,
I just automatically think that.
- Yeah, listen, you default
into the angle, the conspiracy.
You must love conspiracy
fucking documentaries.
It's like that's like, you know,
like that's where you're at.
- Yeah.
- What's so interesting in
the theme of this show is
now you know why you're the
one that looks at other things
and tries to tear people down.
- Yeah, yeah I understand.
- It's all the same game.
I really believe as we go through
this period of time in
American history specifically,
and really in the world,
where hate and negativity
have definitely risen.
- 100%.
- I believe that we're
gonna get into mental health issues
and get into, you know,
parenting structures and like,
and what I'm really worried about
is that a lot of people that are
that think they're kind and good people,
are actually shaming people,
instead of trying to help.
- Right, yeah, I agree with that.
- Of course you do, you are
on the receiving end of that.
- Yes, (laughs) yeah,
I feel like you know,
holy shit, dude, I didn't
even think about it.
Like how you were saying
that, you know, like,
maybe I just, you know, gotta
I think I gotta like work on
it more like on a daily basis
and just exercise it more.
I'm trying to change that
because damn, like it's
I don't even think about it,
I don't know I didn't think about it like
I'm scared of stuff I
just thought about it.
Like, I'm just negative, and like,
I just don't like people that much
and this and that.
- No, no, you don't like yourself.
- Yeah, yeah no that's probably
I really don't like how I am.
I hate that mindset that I have.
- That's right, but the good
news is you could fix it.
I didn't like that I didn't
have you know muscles
and I was not healthy for my heart
and like I was gonna
like, and I changed it
and when I tell you working
out and eating right
did not come natural to me at all.
So I changed I figured it out.
I got a babysitter, a trainer
and I figured out the system
you just have to figure out your system.
Maybe you have maybe you have to listen to
positivity on podcast 24 hours a day.
- That's what I did.
Yeah, I listened to you
every single day like,
all the time.
- And other people too
and I appreciate it,
but like, you know,
like, and maybe me like,
bro, you have to watch
this video like every day.
- Yeah, no I probably will.
This is like the biggest moment ever,
I told my wife this is like top five
like best things like in my life.
- Bro, you are just perfectly cliche
in so many your actions.
I see so many young people
who have this framework.
Get married early.
As soon as they find
somebody, super positive.
- Yeah, yeah it's like
not even realize it.
- First for her.
- Yeah, I really I tell her all the time,
like, "I wish I could be like you.
I wish I could just think
everything's gonna be fine."
And like, you know, like,
I always tell her that
because it's just such a good you know.
- Instead of making it selfish and say,
"I wish I could be like you",
maybe what you can do
is make it a compliment.
You're making it about yourself
when you say that to her.
- Oh shit, I didn't think about it
like that.
- What you might
want to change that to
and this is where
semantics of words matter.
Maybe you say to her, what's her name?
- Naomi.
- Naomi?
- Yeah.
- "Naomi, I admire your
optimism and positivity."
Now all of a sudden, you're
giving her a compliment,
because when you say to her,
"I wish that I could be like you",
She's not taking that as a compliment.
She sees that as you being
selfish about what you wish,
you're about you in that sentence.
- Yeah, that's true.
Yeah, I'm saying, "I wish
I was", you know, yeah.
- And what you're doing
is you're subconsciously,
again saying, "Hey,
like, feel bad for me",
instead of propping her up,
you're asking her for another hand,
almost, there's a
subconscious guilt of like,
"You got lucky with DNA, I didn't."
What's gonna happen with her,
she's gonna build resentment
for you, over time.
- Right, no, I agree 100% with that, yeah.
- Bro I really, really believe in you.
- Thank you, man. I appreciate it.
Like, I don't normally talk
about this with anyone normally.
Like I tried, like I
said, like only with her
but I was like Matt Gary's
like the perfect person
to just put this on, and just see, like,
what his response would be to this.
Like, I've been trying to talk
to you for the longest time,
dude, like, I'm telling you three years,
like I would DM you all the time.
Like when you took out with, like,
came out with this messaging service.
I've messaged you and stuff, you know.
You actually responded
like six months ago.
You were like, "Hey, what's up?"
Because I was like,
"I'm like, I hope you see this."
Then you responded back to it,
and I was like, "Fuck, yeah."
like I saved it, you know?
- I swear to God, on
everything in my body,
I genuinely think you can win this game.
- Thank you, man.
I really like it's life
changing to hear that from you,
you know what I'm saying?
Like it's real.
- Bro, please realize
that you were wounded, you're hurt,
you're not bad, you're
good with an injury.
- Right, yeah, I just didn't realize that.
I didn't think about it,
I didn't I guess, because I'm young too.
So it kind of like you don't
think about that stuff like,
and now I'm like,
"Damn, that's probably what it is,
maybe something happened to me."
Like it just kind of like-
- I don't think
it's usually it's more
of a systematic culture,
like, it's very likely
that one of your parents
is exactly the same way,
and instead of resenting your parent,
you can feel bad for them too.
You can have compassion for them,
instead of now going into a place of like,
"You know what, fuck you mom,
Gary is right, fuck you."
No, no, no you can go into
a place of compassion,
because it's likely that her mom did that,
or your dad's dad did
that, or you understand?
- Yeah, yeah, yeah.
No, I agree with that.
- So it's important that
you realize it's up.
You need to realize that
you're strong enough to
change it for everyone.
- Right.
- Digging in, and drawing the line
and making it a fight,
is gonna do nothing.
- Yeah, and you think like, also,
what you surround yourself with,
also kind of affects you too,
kind of like-
- 100% of course,
I believe that.
It's why I fucking work so hard to
put out so much free content.
I'm trying to be a
positive force for people
that aren't fortunate
enough to have something
and I have a unique communication style
and a human element that clicks
for some people that because
I think they can taste
the lack of interest of
anything other than the extra.
You know, like, I'm not
looking for anything.
- I agree, 100% that's what I said,
when I first started watching your videos,
I didn't think like you
had an angle actually.
Like I was like, "Holy
shit, this guy's like",
and it's I think it's
because you call people
on their bullshit, you know?
And like-
- You know what's funny?
- You know what's funny.
I hear that a lot from from people,
and they like that, you know what's funny?
I think given the tone
of this conversation,
I, I just wanna help.
- Right, yeah.
and that's like, you always preach that
and it really does like work.
That's why I said, like, you do change.
Like I said, even in three years,
I feel like I have gotten better.
You know, maybe I've
gotten worse actually,
at that I isolate myself from people more,
but I have gotten better
in the sense of like,
now, like with YouTube, and
like, other stuff like that,
I'm more confident that I will
be able to make that work.
That's like my other thing
that I'm like-
- You need to realize
that those people aren't
bad or have an angle.
It's that you're scared because you're not
emotionally strong to be let down.
- Yeah, I agree with that.
- You're cutting them out
to protect yourself.
The way to really "win",
is for you to get comfortable
with being let down
and realizing that's
not a reflection of you.
- Right, no I agree with that.
That's awesome, that's
what I needed to hear.
- I'm glad I can deliver it, bro.
- Thank you so much, man.
I really, really appreciate it, dude.
- Alexis, listen to me.
Over next year, a million people
are gonna watch this video.
Just remember, that means
that cutting people out
or trolling someone, or waking
up like you're not gonna
be able to live anymore tricking people,
you're not tricking anyone anymore.
Use that as a positive.
- Yeah, no, dude, trust me.
Like I said, maybe like
hearing it from you since like,
I've always looked up
to you for a long time.
Like I said, in the last three years,
I was like, 19, 20, 21.
So, like, I feel like I
kind of grew up in because,
in those stages of life,
you do grow up to a certain extent.
I feel like watching you
as like, my role model
has kind of like, helped me a lot.
So now I'm actually talking to you,
which is so crazy
and listening to you
say that, my role model.
It's like, "holy shit,
like, you know, yeah,
I need to change I need
to do something like
I can't keep being like this."
- I'm telling you right
now, what most excites me
is I know you can.
- Thank you so much.
- If you knew the power
and strength it took
for you to be honest on this video.
Now living life and
being okay with Ricky if
he like steals your money,
or like says something bad about your wife
and you being a bigger part, like,
you can't imagine now trying
to forgive one of your parents
or an uncle or something, you know,
I don't wanna dive too deep.
It might be something
even more extreme than
just a negative atmosphere.
It might be some real deep shit.
Forgiveness is the fucking
key to a whole new life.
- Yeah, no, I haven't
practiced that yet in my life.
If you know like, I haven't really
I'm not a forgiving
person, so maybe I should.
- That comes out of your own insecurity.
- Yeah.
- Forgiveness, and being the bigger person
and kindness, is the
fucking ultimate strength.
- Yeah, no that's,
I need to do it.
I need to start doing it.
I really do.
- I believe you.
I really think you can.
That's why I'm five minutes
late for a huge client meeting.
- Oh my God, dude, I'm so sorry.
- No, no, no, no, no.
What I want you to hear is that the reason
I'm this late, is because
I feel this moment so much.
I'm also super aware of
how raw and real we went
and how many hundreds of
people right now watching
are living your exact life,
and this, this thing, I genuinely believe,
is the seed of so much of the things
that are anxious in our society.
I desperately, desperately
want to be one of the
forces to fucking help
cut this thing out of our bodies.
- Yeah, no, I mean, we need it.
like the people that are like me, like,
you know, it's like-
- Alexis,
you have an Instagram?
- Yes.
- Because I want this community
to DM you, encourage you
and I want you to make
some positive friends.
What's your Instagram?
- Thank you so much.
It's AlexisCisnero.
- Just the way?
- Yeah, just a way like my name is.
Then underscore, at the end.
- Right after,
mm-hmm.
- Yeah.
- Alexis.
- Yeah right there.
Somebody found it or
Dustin found it, I guess.
That's awesome, holy shit he's fast
(laughs).
- All right
you're 567, 568 now.
- Awesome, thank you
so much.
- You like cars?
- I love cars that's been my passion since
I was like six years old.
- All right 568 Vaynernation.
This would mean the world to me.
I wanna see this number
completely fucking explode.
I want every one of you to DM
this man something positive.
I want please, please.
- Dude,
thank you so much.
I appreciate that so much, man.
Thank you so much.
- Alexis, listen to me.
Please do me one honor.
Please listen to this whole entire thing.
I think it was like 30 minutes.
- Yeah (laughs).
- Often, often.
- Okay.
Thank you so much
- Like literally workout every
morning and listen to this,
or while you're brushing
your teeth every morning.
Every morning, I'm telling you, man.
- Yeah, thank you so much, dude.
I will listen to it.
I mean, trust me,
this is like a huge deal to me.
Like I said, top five life moments.
- It's a huge deal for me too.
- Thank you so much, holy shit.
Like, I didn't I honestly
wasn't even gonna talk to you
about this, I was like,
I had a whole different question,
but then I was like talking
to you and I'm like,
"Damn, like, he's actually
like, as real as it gets, man."
So I was like, "No, I'm
just gonna lay it out."
You know? I was like-
- Alexis, you helped
more people today than most people
ever get to help in their entire life.
- Thank you so much.
- You're a good kid.
You're not negative.
- Thank you.
- You're not bad.
You're mislabeled, bro.
- You're gonna make me cry, dude.
Like holy shit this is like.
- Bro, you're mislabeled.
You're mislabeling yourself to yourself.
You're a wonderful fucking
human who has an injury,
has a vulnerability and has
to completely address that
and change the way you talk
and think and practice that.
You want a real prescription?
Go reach out to everybody in your phone.
Go to your phone right now
and look at from A to Z
and text people and say
you're sorry, and I love you.
That takes real strength.
- Yeah, yeah there's some
people that I'm like,
"Dude, I would never want to even see
this guy's name again."
I don't know why, like,
it's, yeah I need to do that.
- Because you're insecure.
- Yeah, yeah, no I mean,
I agree with that.
- When you do that,
if you get the courage to do it,
when they reply, "Fuck you", understand.
- Yeah.
- Compassion comes from enormous strength.
- Thank you so much, man.
Like I said, this is
this moment right here
I think is definitely
100% life-changing for me.
This is definitely like I said,
I've been doing better in
these last three years,
but I feel it's like that
boost that I need, 100%.
Thank you so much, man.
- I Love you a lot.
Good luck.
- I'm so sorry.
Thank you so much, man.
I love you too, dude.
- Sorry for what?
- Sorry for you being late
(laughs) (indistinct).
- This is the best nine
minutes late in my entire life.
I'm so humbled to have
this moment with you.
What we just did here will forever bring
value to human beings.
I believe it in the depths
of my fucking being.
- Thanks, dude, that means a world to me,
that honestly really means
the world to me, dude.
This is what I needed.
Thank you so much, Gary.
- You're welcome, brother.
- Have a great day, man.
Thank you, you too.
- Bye, bye.
Dustin.
- Very, very, very powerful.
- That really matters, that last one, man.
- Yeah.
- Like that's the whole game.
That right there is the whole
game I see in the world.
- I feel very similar.
Like there's a lot of people in my world
that I've kind of dropped
and I've wanted to reach out,
but I'm just afraid that
they're gonna be like,
- "Fuck you."
- "Fuck you
or like, whatever loser,"
or something like that.
- Bro, don't do things for
other people's reactions.
Do them for you, and for the karma,
and even if they tell you, "Fuck you",
they'll always know where you stood.
Because right now, they
think you stand with fuck you
and you might be doing
a blessing for them.
Because that may inspire them
to do it for somebody else,
even if they don't reply to you.
- Yeah.
- There's nothing more
noble than, "I'm sorry."
(sighing)
If you can do it in an audio or video,
where they can not lose the
tone of the written word,
it's even more powerful man.
Dustin, you can do it.
Bro you're here with me now like come on,
you can do that.
You should.
- Yeah, you're right.
It's good.
Putting out more good is good, you know?
This is what we fucking need, man.
This is it's time.
We've gone too long with not
making this the way we go.
You're gonna feel lighter.
- I mean, I did start like,
someone sent me something
to like make fun of someone
and I was like, I DM them like,
"Hey, someone sent this to
me to like make fun of you",
and I was like, "No, I'm not doing that.
Like, I actually respect
what you just put out.
So I just want to say that
and any bad taste you having
about me from the past?
I just wanna apologize for that too."
I mean, I can reply, but
at least I've tried, so.
- No, not tried, executed.
You're not doing it for him to reply.
You brought value to him
and you brought value to yourself.
You won with that, I'm
so proud of you, man.
That's humongous.
- Thanks.
Right down the list from
fucking A to Z in your,
address book write down the list.
(laughing)
Listen,
I mean you were hurting.
- Yeah.
- I know you well enough to understand it.
Do it. It's so nice to do, it's so good.
You're a different man now.
- Yeah.
- We'll see tomorrow on Tea with GaryVee.
(upbeat music)
The people that are
gonna win over the next
five to seven years are
gonna be very comfortable
in controlled fucking chaos.
You don't love the process.
This is (indistinct)
we're talking about,
rules require sacrifice.
All of your actions have
to then map to a it.
Backpack, backpack, backpack.
Nobody gives a shit
about where you grew up.
The whole game is scaling the unscalable.
It's fucking hard work.
It's being respectful.
It's being a good person
That's just a good idea.
It's there, the footings there,
this house right here is $400.
I stay in my lane, like
real fucking tight.
But you can't be crippled.
Everybody here is judging themselves.
You're looking at what's
in front of you right now.
You're losing because
you're laying in your bed
looking at somebody's fucking glamorous,
photoshopped picture of
them doing something cool,
and you're envious, and you're
jealous and you're impatient.
and it's crippling your upside.
Let me just say one more time,
if you're confused what I just said.
I say put your fucking flag on the ground
of who the fuck you are.
Whoever provides the
most value always wins.
You're entering the greatest
five-year window of your life.
My only answer to me, or
anybody like is just like,
try shit, shut your business down
and go work for an apparel
company for 10 years.
Nobody you've ever met got
there without the hard work.
So you better get your speed up.
You better work harder,
you better work smarter.
(upbeat music continues)
You can't Google stuff,
you're not gonna be able to do anything
that I'm telling you to do.
GaryVeeTV my new account.
Check me out, hope you enjoy it.